Mày sau thằng sau, chính phủ gặp buc chia chính thức định đơn lên toàn công li của tế RCC yêu cầu phần sự chẳng chấp biên rồi với thái lan tại một khu vực tà mua thông, tà mua thông, tà mua thông, tà grabay và mông bay, thủ tướng hôm nay khẳng định động thái này, giằm tiêm kiểm giải pháp phá bình, công bằng và mình bạch dựa trên đối pháp buc tế,
tên kia đã được lại xưa các buc chia tại Hà Lan, trực tiếp chuyển tới chủ sở RCC ở tờ hóc. Đông thái dịn giang,
ngay sau của học lần thứ sấu của 8 biến dở chung, các buc chia thái lan, tổ trức tại Phnom Penh ngày 14, đến mấy làm thằng sấu sau 1 2 3 đoạn.
Fíc thái lan cho biết, chưa nhận được thông bảo chuyến thức từ các buc chia hòa RCC, đông thời nhấn mắt nước này không công nhận thầm quyền của RCC,
kể từ những năm sống mười của thế kỳ chó. Bông gà giáo thái lan cũng đã thành lập nhỏ pháp li ý để trình bị phạt đứng trong trường hợp cần thiết.
Chủ tức thông viện cám phù chia ông hình xem trên mổ, cám phù chia không tìm kiểm đối đầu quân sư mà mong muốn cậu đồng của tế ông hộ giải pháp pháp li ý,
ông cạnh bảo sẽ cấm nhất hầu toàn bộ trái kây và rau cù từ thái lan, nếu các cơ khẩu không được mở lãnh ngày trong ngày mề sợ thằng sấu,
chẳng chấp biến dở dở hai nước giao dài hơn một thế kỳ, bắt ngồn từ quả trình phân liết đường dân dởi giao pháp,
mổ quốc của kapu chia thật kiện thật liệt. A phản quyết năm 2019 và 20 2018,
tông nhận chủ quyền kapu chia đồ về đền Bia và Hia và khu vực xung quanh, nhưng thái lan không công nhận.
Dất đến nhiều vụ đúng độ bên giới trong những năm qua, đình điểm bản đầy một cuộc lâu xung ngày hai mề tạm thằng năm,
giữa lực lượng hai bên đã kể một bình sĩ kapu chia thêm mạc.